en direct le chef libéral Justin Trudeau
le chef conservateur Andrew Shearer la
cruche du NPD rencontre Singh Elizabeth May du
Parti Vert le chef du Bloc Québécois e
François Blanchette et Maxine Bernier
du Parti Populaire leur objectif de
vous convaincre de donner votre
vote à leur parti les modérateurs sont cinq des
les journalistes politiques les plus respectés du pays
le cadre est l'une des
institutions les plus remarquables du Canada
le Musée de l'histoire à Gatineau
Québec c'est le débat ici sont vos dirigeants
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bienvenue au débat des chefs 2019 je
veux dire j'y suis encore allé  m sous m.  na
agua fait des autruches homme yung-shiu Peter
Gargi va avoir été la montre un chemin là-
dedans je suis sous l'ordonné jeune homme
Peter a basica tout au long du débat
devenu vidéo sommes-nous dans un monsieur je suis dans la
guerre le John et ça  euh faire kid aa
thèmes majeurs ce soir et kid sur un
nouveau moi et débattu d'un enfant dont je suis celui
qui en a marre donc les thèmes de ce soir des
milliers de dirigeants leur répondront en
fonction de ce sera simulacre suis un
enfant imbattable je veux dire le  celui qu'ils manquent d'
accord va débattre ce soir un homme Fiona
répond donc les dirigeants sont tous d'accord
quand euh diamant a fait pipi sur un bâton un arc un
nouveau non anoxique arrive M&B plus sombre Anna
Tom de jure je sais et puis la
vignette le clic quand L va gamma
Les dirigeants de Tom Regan Kida, je suis dans un
gamin, pas de merde, d'
accord, de nombreux Canadiens ont senti que de nombreux
Canadiens ont ressenti les implications d'
un monde divisé plus que 2015 de
notre planète Ian's Montanan une option, je
suppose, à nos tensions croissantes avec la Chine en
tant que Premier  Ministre,
comment voulez-vous  u si comment va votre morceau celui
sur lequel je suis que j'obtiendrai mon utilisation des
Canadiens et andum merci
numérique Wow quand anima Mundi les
Canadiens 45 secondes Merci mr.
national sous la société du circuit des bonnes affaires
moi Gresham et Peter homme Pataki agita une
agonie continue Nina non pas eux mois même
à la politique basée sur la peur car c'était un mois
particulier auquel les gens sont
confrontés, nous devons nous assurer que cet
outil de rire de gars soit  capable de réussir avec
moi dans un certain monde et c'est pourquoi au
cours des
dernières années, même Valjean Argonia quand
il babouinait le matin Donna Deveny Anna
Anna mes pieds Enochian j'ai dit ouais
défi massif et pressant et
construire une économie plus forte pour le
nan de Fukushima et  puis le Nokia et
Nagi Nika un atout important ce soir
encore un nouveau crewmen et anoxique Aminta
merci je suis anglais le People's Party
et on met Nina en arabe M&P où
ils s'ennuient ils sont tous gay market pour
acheter une place au  Le coronium de la sécurité des Nations Unies est
en décomposition alors ils vous donnent de l'
argent pour lutter contre le changement climatique
Je suis sous un livre Shui plus grand parmi la
noix de coco Hecky vous gagnez gagagigo nama pour
lutter pour notre pays en fait moi pourquoi
Miska e  à est la base d'Amazon en arme à feu Amanda a
obtenu la Chine au Canada parce que ce qu'ils
ne sont pas capables merci la prochaine
opportunité pour mr.  Singh pour répondre m.
Monsieur.  Donna puante comme en kazakh mais Donna
Jimmy glitch Canada Je suis sous un
meegwetch meegwetch le leadership concerne
Nina oh allez l'honneur d'Okanagan et
si jean est un cas banal d'
Anishinabe debout pour l'emporter sur n'importe quel
bling savez-vous un atout de
meilleurs accords commerciaux qui  en fait,
poussez d'abord vos besoins pour moi la
question avec les Canadiens Niigata Kannamma
tout est allé jusqu'à l'intérêt puissant et riche
des entreprises qui sont
lundi en train de ruiner un démagogue sa honte
le jour si son libéral sait était un
Mandela Ottawa et sur le mélange Neil
va rire  que H est Anya et que leur
natif va là-bas et que je ne suis pas en forme dans
le problème de cheminée, M. Shearer kidnappe l'
opportunité avec nany Blin Oh Canada et
défend nos intérêts tout autour aux États
-Unis et que j'irais pendant que nous assistons
à Justin  Trudeau kid geekus
il ne peut pas parce que ooh-gah donne des concerts et
allez c'est que c'était notre seul sur
Argos Je suis comme un jour peut-il gagner alors je
veux que le procureur général soit le premier
d'entre vous  nna Montpetit auditeur un
masque féministe puis trouvé dans Nick
nous avons maintenant la fenêtre sur sa
corruption il met sur un homme de la classe moyenne
est sorti et souvent euh tu gagnes assez
mr.  Trudeau Monica de ta fraude et toi
Diego assez gaawiin gaggle negan maman plus âgée
et P double Canada Tom attrape ce
cadet ou je leur manque j'aimerais en fait
répondre à la question de Rica la conscience
ne peut pas l'obtenir peut-être que les cheveux me regrettent d'
aller Algonquin réputation d'être un
un courtier honnête voudra peut-être qu'elle quitte pour
embrasser un inany boo là-dedans pour continuer, ce qui
signifie notre avenir en tant que Gandhi
Amanda mondain ce que nous un royaume et Kenda chantons
comme si nous marchions commandant l'Organisation mondiale du commerce
et en faisons une organisation
qui promeut
loin  Amanda ash way livre bien là mon
lundi je soutiens l'état de droit et
l'addendum humain Ditka Amani Toomer gay
protect Canaan est entré ou gamma changeant
la scène mondiale monsieur l'effusion de sang
Frank le moment est merde le mur
manemma cependant d'abord le bonsoir
tout le monde et merci pour  ne m'ayant pas
une Coquina morte anoxique
ayant du leadership ou faisant preuve de
leadership parfois besoin de
ne pas faire dans le cou lancinante et
Holger Martin la fin financière en chef
officier ancial amanada aronia pour
qui les agriculteurs dessinent alors ouais
Agata est parti un homme pris okie winema papier
les cœurs quand vous faites face à un
ennemi puissant quand s sur le web le rien de bon elle
et la Chine si vous n'avez que de minuscules biceps un
anniversaire de Bunge en soi  vous avez appris et nous
soutiendrions quelqu'un avec un vrai leader
je veux dire propre et euh les filles courent un peu
plus beaucoup en faisant un filet minéral d'
accord max lundi okoma Canada quand l'
homme Escudero à un leader choisi je suis dans
le
chef du parti populaire wah et euh minuit  Maxine beignets dans
l'eau qui est à Bernie pour débattre de lui
mais mr.  Bernier tu aimes tordre là
Bernie un
pika da clé alors qu'elle commençait à le tweeter tu as
appelé la diversité au Canada un culte Je veux que
ce gamin comprenne que tu étais appelé
et que la tribu s'entend euh arriver aux tribus demander
si un mois sur Greta  syntoniser Berg le
modèle climatique de seize ans, elle ne
sait pas si nous étions possédés,
je suis à nouveau, il doit faire un rapide il n'y a
pas de cours le lundi pour diriger tous les
Canadiens économiques là-dessus quand Ash maintenant
je suis le  Madiga a obtenu des Canadiens, vous
devez dire la vérité aux Canadiens si vous
voulez être le chef de ce contenu
dans le blâme et cher garçon gagnez le mois
des Canadiens amers Roi Votre Majesté, vous
devez être fier de cette
madame d'accord maman dommage Amen propre et je suis
capable  pour nous dire qui est votre gargy ghormeh
alors qu'elle a commencé
le pistolet mezzanine d'une mère Mondo avec l'
immigration, je dis que nous devons être
l'article dans l'
article assurez-vous que ces personnes participent l'
abandon nominal est un grand pays
mais c'est une occasion minérale et amanda
nous  je ne veux pas que notre pays b  e comme d'
autres pays d'Europe
Binda est allé là-bas Gomorrhe était lundi
est-elle pita Canada je veux dire le canadien je
veux dire pas
été la porte d'entrée sur ce misérable je suis
dans l'Agee Kedah mr.singh euh le
tempérament requis pour un bon leader
au milieu, ils vont devenir fous et ensuite je
veux dire que tu pourrais juste dire hey mec j'ai
foiré je veux dire d'accord vas-y il
pourrait y avoir un retour et vraiment pour moi je veux dire
devrait venir signifier les yeux je crois qu'un
leader n'est pas ce qui s'est arrêté  les gens ou
pour monter les gens les uns contre les autres un vrai
leader donc pas de ponts légitimes rassemblant les
gens ça va aller Ning Mundi non
ok Monda lundi
Hakeem je ne vois pas de dopage ceux
au sommet que nous avons vu avec les
gouvernements à Ottawa depuis longtemps  trop longtemps
je suis sous leur véhicule prenait que
les milliardaires d'Ottawa ils reçoivent un impôt massif sur
les sociétés comme Ronnie je suis sur le
milliard kid mama continue c'est une
arme à feu si elle Nokia je suis sous un Keith mais
mais mais ouais ba-gawk  ne peut pas se connecter et
le si en demande  Anishinabe Madonna car
wingait quand il y a le webinaire pourrait
être celui que Nick est bon et bien sûr ils le
font quand le whoa mr.  Bernier et c'est
maintenant l'occasion de venir sur Pete Donna
kid un cadet de Sheerness ce que mr.  Bernier
échoue sous la sœur Bernie
absolument être fier de l'histoire du Canada,
vous pouvez être important en eux garder ce
qu'Ana un Canada je suis moi Raja un peon Mondamin
dans la guerre un Gurkha na oo ee un lundi je
vois un Canada fort du Canada à cause
de notre  liberté notre liberté de savoir
absolument alors l'économe va un garçon de papier
allez Peter ils peuvent dire que c'est une victoire
l'homme candidat p10 et ensuite avec le
niqab ou pas tu as changé de
quelqu'un qui avait l'habitude d'aller je ferais mieux de
reculer et  ça va croire et quand
ils montrent mon Raja ici et
maintenant,
nous faisons votre politique pour que
Amazo le liquide mère ningún mais
n'est-ce pas euh parce qu'elle a commencé Monica
étaient des célébrations c'est ce que je veux dire posséder
et eux  quand Peter notre roi up Annette
min wash King Gorgon ah [ __ ] atone besoin
de marcher nous croyons que nous croyons qu'il faut rendre le
Canada plus fort Canada lorsque vous montrez
le gaya à notre pays et célébrez
les choses qui nous ont rendus formidables en tant que
nation et propre fin le  Je veux dire posséder un
mois, je pense que je comprends la
question Lisa, c'était aussi les
caractéristiques d'un gars qui va à Amman
Panetta et et euh qui obtiendra machina
une fin
bonne merde obtiendra mon seigneur sur
tout le monde oh tu vas  repartir
génial et nous voulons travailler maintenant les femmes
leur introduction ce soir en disant qui
sera invité à revenir je suis allé tout dire
quel homme p1p wa travailler et être un
service public je crois qu'elle a commencé une
session qui a dit que je pensais quand cet
enfant vers le bas et  cela pourrait être fait et un
homme pita en la matière
Madhavan me connaît Nene signifie Dieu, nous pourrions
ils obtenir la marche encore une fois parce que vous
connaissez une arme à feu Amazon n'importe quoi et Menon
et elle est devenue un ninja des
pays socialistes comme le Venezuela Le Venezuela a beaucoup
empiré et euh hé  J'ai un livre Shui, un
crevetteur, allez Pig Akiko ouais, [ __ ],
épine et pas le Walker, je veux dire que cet enfant
pourrait être que nous disons que les hommes de Mendham ont été
le Gonder
guamazo avant de sauter, mais le bug
est si vrai ne devrait-il pas être quelqu'un
ré  enying le changement climatique va à l'anglaise le
paternalisme de Bachman semble venir un
peu trop je vois que
tu détestes dix secondes le queendom qu'une
vache dans l'élément pitié après moi désordre
pugazh toboggans je parie à environ le double
Gong afin de lundi accueillir aussi
dans la plongée du Canada  dans le jeu et minhwa
lundi Canada pour qu'ils partagent notre
langue Aggie Kedah et les munitions dans une
source canadienne sont investies dans ce que
c'est réalisable
oh ouais moi non moi non de cette façon les enfants quand
vous jouez Isaac vous obtenez les données aériennes
quelles étaient  ils Amanda quel nom québécois
le pourcentage de balayage de la chanson nationale va le
nom de l'aigle ici vient notre population maintenant en
allant et euh Amanda aqui aqui a Canada
gowing's God can man
fini okay et le débat final sur le
sujet revient à mr.  L'épopée de Trudeau
parle d'un enfant sur peut-être qu'il est mort
quand nment être dominant et maintenant quand dans le
numéro un D bien ici et montior
sait ce qu'ils ne sont pas devenus ils vont
est un billet d'un mois de haut alors ils disent que
tu veux  frapper l'incertitude dans
le cœur des gens et soulever ceux qui me manquent
Bentley et ils sont sur ce doggy va
à Bernie
rôle d'essayer de causer chez les gens plus
craintifs alors qu'ils vont à leur
quai dans l'opportunité de
continuer à redéfinir chaque jour
ce  est-ce qu'un minimum peut avoir ces
cookies là ouais alors que nous, en
tant que dirigeants, vous avez toujours
voulu qu'un œuf se produise alors et
et je suis fier d'être canadien comme vous Amanda
un lundi canadien pendant ce temps ce pays
doit être comme ça dans  25 ans que nous aimons ce
pays et ce n'est pas parce que je voulais une
discussion minérale et je suis ici
à nigga das vu pour cent six pour cent
empanada
donc Amanda un appât canadien à propos du fait que
vous n'êtes pas en ligne avec la population il y a à
peine une semaine dans le M  bouleverser un martien
islamique évidemment tellement de couches à la
question du leadership donc cette question
vient d'un orateur qui lui pose une
question de Calgary encore une fois pas de cage mais
les gouvernements provinciaux et le
gouvernement fédéral sont sur des longueurs d'onde différentes
finagle un deux patrouilleurs provinciaux
qui apparaît sur  ce joug va juste
venir de l'eau en travaillant avec la
province - jeu sur - devinez quel gang
rendra quelqu'un dangereux mais
Matsui basé sur un tirage au sort cela va
à mr.  Bernier d'abord, puis tous les
autres remue Bernie un automne Sherman les a
tout d'abord je respecterai
la Constitution
venez pas et fait homme docteur ne
va pas avoir peur dans la
juridiction provinciale kagerou va carré donc je
vais faire défiler les malades provinciaux nous ne pouvons pas
en  Ottawa résout les défis que rencontraient
les wapitis Je parle d'accord ce
qui ne va pas travailler transfère l'argent
aux provinces et ce que je ferai tu
sais qu'elle va Tommy Nanak provincial
nous savons que nous Mick plus le transférons pas
chaotique  longtemps pour faire face à cela et ce
sera les provinces - suryanarayana
nous savons que je voulais rencontrer mr.
stinkman vraiment, elle a évoqué de nombreuses
préoccupations que les Canadiens ont et même
Omar obtiendra de Dunham qu'il le ferait et
comment le mode macho de McQuinn pour moi est l'
une des plus grandes préoccupations
précises où Akshar a dit que Will a une
maladie chronique et doit payer pour son
la famille doit payer les médicaments et les
injections dont j'aurai besoin à propos des
connexions de mars beurk nous vivons dans un moment
obscur, la fin du département du Nippon
et les échos sont plus importants je veux
dire à ce jeune l'optimisme face à l'
excès maigre miracle de lavage bien ajusté et
enfilé  Je ne sais pas ce que je ne peux pas faire pour la paix, nous
ne pouvons pas bien parler, les conservateurs ont
toujours reconnu l'importance de
travailler avec les provinces que nous
complotions.
chose que je peux promettre aux
électeurs de tout le pays d'obtenir
une contravention, vous allez au tribunal pour lutter contre des choses
comme la taxe sur le carbone et m.  Trudeau a
imposé toutes les grandes attaques contre les
provinces qui ne veulent pas plaider
un jeu à coût élevé ce carbone Ibaka no
gentleman DeCosta l'essentiel de tous les jours
comme l'essence chauffage de la maison mon lit aucun enfant
Marvel ne peut se demander si un
jour d'embaumement vous rencontrer le gouvernement conservateur
sous  mon leadership va brouiller le
carbone Nicci rotation nigga faire midi
ne peut pas Donna greens la
coopération est dans notre ADN aucun des
problèmes que nous résolvons et auxquels nous sommes confrontés
ne sera résolu si nous continuons à nous
disputer et à nous battre les uns avec les autres
allez mec nous avons tous  fin ouverte nous
ne nous asseyons pas sur notre mandir
n'ouvrons pas un amendement de Panera quittons
l'ISM non mathématique calqué sur ce que
nous voulons juste entrer et la
guerre du Parti vert que jeune nous ne boudons pas le
territoire que tous les hommes sont des
compagnons municipaux provinciaux et tout  chemin autour de la
même table trouver un terrain d'entente peut à
nouveau pénis Novick Miki ok non à savoir
dr.  Barthold
est un commandant Waco merci
vous savez mr.  provancha
dans une étude aujourd'hui sur de mr.  Eric
maan Singh dit que cette campagne
ne porte pas sur les questions rurales mais sur
les questions provinciales et québécoises, par exemple annulée, c'est la
coopération avec les provinces ou l'
homologation québécoise Wyndham névrosé de la
reine maman je ne suis pas une religieuse je ne devrais pas
sortir à Montauk c'est un visuel  sur de nombreuses
questions, à
quoi ressemble la marche comme la noix de coco Marshall,
notre argent étant mis en scène par le
gouvernement fédéral pour nous rendre
avec des conditions Nina drone je ne
parle pas longtemps du poulet Mactan sans
punition avec deux hommes sur votre menu
Anaya et même d'autres ont dit non cliquez sur un
on me connaissait un peu maintenant je ne
rencontrais plus les premiers ministres lors des
réunions des premiers ministres, alors nous avons redémarré que lorsque nous avons
pris le pouvoir en 2015, nous n'étions pas beaucoup de
lagopèdes dans un squat Kanagawa mati
dans les soins à domicile, pas seulement travailler et nous
continuons à travailler  avec les provinces sur la
renégociation pour obtenir le transport
peut ouvrir notre lorsque les femmes ne prennent jamais ne peuvent
que ne pas être végétaliennes modernes dans leur
deuxième ville natale Jason Kenney et Doug Ford et ont
pensé t  ici, quand nous avons eu les
provinces de mélanine à Carter, nous avons monté asunción
canard Unwin monkey et je voulais aller de
l'économie me canonique lundi à venir
très prochainement, nous sommes un leader une chance de
poser à n'importe quel autre leader une question sur n'importe quel
sujet que nous connaissons cette semaine  eux cela a été
choisi par tirage au sort le premier chef
cette fois est nous savons que nous n'allons pas
connaître ceux que vous pouvez avec tamale regardez-
moi parler
nous savons que vous connaissez un animal avec Dada
connaissez l'éducation riche et coupée et
puis-je en obtenir un  il y a un wapiti Eric tu
sais que je suis dr.  boogie oak ma question est que
vous critiquez mr.  Harper sur le sien était
formidable mais vous ne parvenez pas à les atteindre
Je dois crier Abed
et parler de la prudence de Harper non mobile
ensemble Harper et les conservateurs en
donnant Billy Harsha ensemble vous avez donné 14
millions de plus ne devrait même pas un tsunami
pas sur le kimchi du moteur d'attelage
whoosh mâle 14 millions ou Megumi frappe
à la porte les élèvent pour les 1% les plus riches
et sur le changement climatique après dix ans de
Stephen Harper ne faisant rien de moins qu'une nouvelle
application sur mobile aller génome Harper pour tomber
malade Saucony gentil donne aussi beaucoup de sternum
sous et aussi étang  trimestres 2030 ma
mère ne peut pas obtenir avec un
deuxième mois anémique intersecté je veux dire un nous
frappons neiguan Sonya moi continuons
nous continuons non seulement à promouvoir citrique nous ne
parlons pas trop personne ne pensait quand et
tout ce que nous devrions vérifier le Canada a
jamais  eu ce sont les choses que nous
allons déplacer pour moi aucun fait une
Megan sur une semaine parmi hors de la pauvreté
avec nos investissements sur overwatch que
vous pouvez donner à ma Nanak et de notre chic  k
le Mott sais que tu sais bien aller à gauche
ou non
en élastique tu sais ce que tu as le
débat ouvert sur cette question c'est pour
quatre minutes mr.  Singh vous pouvez commencer
merci regardez les antécédents de
ce gouvernement et en réalité nom -
connaisseur de café conga a en fait payé
moins d'impôts chez les enfants MJ Grenache à
Bogota Seok Lee honish est venu de son propre chef
non seulement votre ministre des Finances a utilisé
la taxe offshore Archer  paradis mais aussi le
président du Conseil du Trésor elle a aussi
utilisé vous savez nous n'avons pas le
chef d'orchestre Tony je suis la cuisine pas de fumée
pour venir oh allez Doc
thermostatique nous savons monter sur Minnesota
avoir une mesure sur notre le gouvernement
était '  même sur nous avons eu une énorme bagarre avec
les Canadiens les plus riches et Jimmy a fait
parler Megan avec Donek la vérité va
rouvrir et accorder des allégements fiscaux donc nous
reniflons des milliers de dollars mourons les
Canadiens les plus riches vous nous devons
nous vouloir jeu sur M. Shearer
conseguido sortez obtenez votre propre chèque tricheurs fiscaux
vous avez appelé des entrepreneurs qui ont créé des
emplois conduction allez commencer
vous savez que les hivers font beaucoup penser que nous
voulons vous obtenir un chèque mais cela pourrait
ruiner vos détracteurs tout simplement ne pas faire
ils dépensent des réductions d'impôts avec moi
aujourd'hui non monté d'un cran vers le panache
ne peut pas commencer à partir de maintenant aller au gothique personne
ne sait même tout le voyage à celui-ci
maintenant notre Stargate sera à cette nuit
mr.  Trudeau n'a pas changé les
objectifs climatiques de ceux de m.  Harper il
faut dire très mademoiselle crème ou
sectaire Kong chez mr.  Trudeau geezer pour l'
amener sur le Nam, nous ne sommes que des automates
, la bande dessinée n'est pas configurée pour Sonata, c'est une
cible pour perdre.
faire la fête avec un plan
avec le seul Parti vert un marché du vin
quand je suis en route et ça va fermer tu
deviens dur Pullman nous connaissons une telle [ __ ]
mondo
en ligne avec la science ton plan est celui-ci
quelle science as-tu trouvé avec le GIEC
le rapport est un maintien du réchauffement à moins de 1,5
degrés que vous aimez dire et il s'agit
vraiment de se moquer du
génome de la mère yashodha et d'accord la crise climatique dans laquelle
nous sommes va nécessiter du courage
sachez ce que Nemo du klom ils appellent
entrer rapidement ou  quiaca normatif que nous
rencontrons n'a pas besoin de faire squatter une femme
ne veut pas que nous sachions grand-chose sur ce
document de contagion à moins de ne pas prédire en
avant ici sur cette scène il n'y a qu'un
seul plan que les sénateurs experts ne seront
pas analytiques dr.  légat Abacha gothique moi
avec le manteau ordre du jour intéressant Nina
katana le jeu d'un régime de compromis d'
un cirque - juste d'accord le cri d'un
pur genre de condos dans mondo le
changement climatique mondial reconnaissant que
peut signifier Erskine dans un déménagement de chenil que vous
attendez  venir en finir avec le
contrôle complet du Congrès national de Punta Gorda du Canada vérifier l'armement Nakia n'était
pas plus sur un condo voici des femmes
savons-nous que nous savons boutonné tué
Pietschmann au large de Jimmy vous a Cano Vega
[Musique]
bonjour je suis al théoriser de  son premier
Canada un bozo en bonne santé Arras le
pétitionnaire parce que je vais Andaman pier
par Matsui notre auditeur et le bikaner
Olga mah Ching Bill 21 mr.  Nash abhishek
j'aime les avec eux ce lundi au Québec
lundi provincial et Nokia ouais je suis allé
à Amanda obtenir de la merde d'accord Amanda Amanda
et ce n'est pas du bacon je suis allé être
Donna pas bon lundi tina sais ce que ce
n'est pas une base la guitare de Burgas assez
évidente la  les gens que je suis Monica
darnisha gaw nous entrons, puis le
projet de loi dans l'est d'Asha Parekh, il
se trouve qu'un homme que Peter a garni le numéro
sous le Canada peut y en avoir un puis
et le dos en ce moment je ne suis sous aucun
gagnant non op le  écrou je suis sous Québec
ils peuvent être un prof y aller Kino
Kino moche et maintenant une tasse et je vais nous nous sommes rencontrés
il y a le coeur d'accord allez y
minhwa et je sais donc dans les engrenages j'ai un
Shui mais prenez le contrôle Sunnah le quand Kenan
et John et moi ne sommes pas tout à fait des services, je
crois fermement et je m'assure que nous nous attaquons à
leur arme d'accord, ils influencent le
gouvernement et cela ne permet pas d'
y aller pour s'assurer que nous construisons des
services qui élèvent les gens je suis en
tandem  nani win et le slovaque  peut être
fait je suis ANGLAIS mon Dieu va là-bas qui
va juste penser et c'est sur le
va rencontrer Keith Allen et pas pressé d'arrêter
ces types d'actes racistes dans le passé
je suis sur PNG maintenant aller pendant cette campagne un
quand je crois que c'est  très important j'ai
besoin de moi
trevean dans cette voiture nous l'obtenons nous donnons
l'ensemble de laine dans lequel je suis et et poussin et
le Monona
ba-ba-ba-ba Missouri connaissent et Monessen les
thèmes de cette discussion cette
polarisation et ils leur prêtent la clé
façon quand la polarisation kabak une autre
chose qui se passe dans notre pays en
ce moment quand je suis dans wha
Amanda une clé ce qui se passe, c'est que les gens
sont quand à heesu
Annika ailier parmi le wigwam Peeta il n'y a
pas de clé sur cette affaire pas la faute d'une
puissante société qui vient c'est un
faute sur les femmes et ces hommes icky icky et
snob un câble canadien est de retour au
travail 12 heures par jour et c'est ce que
mais bien sûr et aucun Kiran Maliki n'a continué
alors Enochian Papa chigamik Westmont M.
Shearer miss make it up Andrew kid on
any can connection ca  mp quiz in and
then them
oh whoops go on est malade allez Dickie
Walter se balancer Mina a fait son travail
quand il a demandé une clé quel est le meilleur je suis
allé quand même Mina fédéral Olga McGuirk
combattant ce debecker ma mascotte Amanda
Amanda et le maire d'accord quelle ville  et de l'
argent pour mon article de jeu garçon un peu sait-
il que la victoire de Mondamin Piazza
touche également bien le projet de loi 21 est bien sûr
polarisant le projet de loi nishta nasha Pékin hé
vous savez euh des sociétés puissantes que je lui ai procuré
un Nokia junior sur Mama's Gioia un
certain nombre  et manœuvrer un fou rire parce que
ceux au sommet ne paient pas leur
juste part poisson par minute s pinga
ailier
ouais ouais ouais on va y aller tu
veux avoir une mascotte mr.  blonde secouez-le
là-bas, elle l'a acheté
Madison a dit le plus grand sur la motion
de donner soutenant le projet de loi
addenda du québec lundi imaginez des armes à feu 21
mr.  Nash a - en gros, il y a un problème de facture
au Québec, c'est le problème, c'est que et
oui, pourquoi pas une blague, une note de service
là-dedans pourrait être de cette façon des problèmes avec
l'idée même alors et eux parce
qu'il n'y a pas de traduction exacte pour ce
mot maintenant dans  concert là-bas, gamin, il y a des cas où
ce gamin ah Québec va quand Esther JA
un gay gay ou pas en tant que nation
c'est un projet de loi qui dit juste aux gens à
cause de la façon dont ils ont l'air d'un
pistolet au kicker da da nous rigolons rigolons
rire Wien T tweet va aller monsieur
baise ce que nous devrions faire est un peu
porte pas aller dans la laveuse eu besoin de les
promener dans le vin nommons la bière LPG
Renea whoa chica va aller
meegwetch autant que chanter un vrai amiguito
kia kia da  madame vous avez parlé très
éloquent ameno nen domeki chat la propre
vie un jardinier dans un peu vous a entendu
dire comme tous les autres coins eggy ne peut pas
se laver
O'Day alguma intervenir dans la voiture
plats sevrés gagner un lundi Amazon dans le projet de loi sur les armes à feu
mr.  Nash Abhishek c'est très poster
rougir un gamin que nous sommes oui dire
étiquette Kadam et être le nouveau moment
faut protéger un trochée protéger un
mois bat geek un Dornish pas de tonte et
nous plus gagnants va lundi ganar Nene
Amanda aqui éventuellement
en débat  et l'Asie se remet à
Costner avec ma pizza chaque jour de
ma vie cet air d'applaudissement difficile
pas d'argent soit ma vie une nouvelle génétique car vous
devez sentir que aussi beaucoup de
gens à travers notre pays à qui on dit
parce que Henderson choisit parmi venir
sous un gang clé et fusillant la NASA
gaspille le grand mur oh mon dieu mon dieu j'ai
rencontré Bernie toute la journée et le Tomica da à
propos du projet de loi 21 nous devons respecter pour
venir en tant qu'interniste ou pas sûr de la
construction de base des points tout le gouvernement
soit je suis  par un enfant provincial sur le gouvernement inna winna
P Amanda Amazon Inga un nouveau
moi oh ma tu sais vérifier que tout peut bien
plus de gamma
Binda va venir chérie
Annie chérie quand est évité un
filet d'indemnité l'aube après la base e  e bonne affaire
dit midi un homme anoxique Peters va faire
ce que l'infirmière un homme et devenir gay va le
chercher
j'ai eu besoin de marcher pendant ce temps je
fais le travail et je suis Nicholson je
vais les réparer là pas cool dis maman
où maman mon lundi hockey IKEA d'
accord
Mendoza
mène de cette façon cadet Mandakini Je suis un
Canada austère je suis sous une page Kedah de l'Université de
la Colombie-Britannique en kazakh ça
Arnett
salut bonsoir un bozo min anoxique toxique
beaucoup signifie anoxique minimun lundi UBC
britannique mécanisation claire
polarisations Canada et puis eux puis
cette rondelle optique comment va ton chef je suis
allé un lundi
j'ai besoin de raccommoder une maman ou un cornichon kiddo
nigga merde nommer la notion dans un
contre les bougres je suis anglais moi
agression kiddo
nous parlons de la  divisions qu'on a
dans notre dans notre pays y'a toi dans
ce cadet Kedah un mois y'a la
radicalisation y'a pas d'emploi
y'a un climat qui permet la semaine
où eux le carré en réserve un autre
parce qu'ils s'inquiètent pour t  l'avenir, il
y a beaucoup de club quand ils en ont
un, j'ai besoin de Garnett mon lundi je veux dire
quoi ouais et nous continuons ce gars à nouveau
pourrir regarde-le je suis indatable une grande partie de
la polarisation consiste à s'assurer que les gens
obtiennent les choses de base dont ils ont besoin
allez Peter Nokia en a frappé un bien,
c'est très sûr que l'enfant appartient et je suis quelque chose que
je suis dans le pays un lundi au Canada, je
souhaite que l'homme Maji mange de l'acacia
ouais je veux dire et je suis Neha je veux dire qu'ils sont
je vais dire allez dans le nahji Moazzam et
ici Amanda d'
accord nous sommes finis ils sont rois je suis sûr
que les gens qui viennent ici embrassent cette
Amanda je comprends si bien lanceur Wendell
maintenant quand et Amanda Yamaha ministre comme
Justin Trudeau mais je te comprends  Oh jeu
terminé, le Premier ministre doit deux doses et
un langage haineux pour les homosexuels pour diaboliser
quiconque n'est pas d'accord avec un chien qui va chez sa
mère en désaccord avec son échec
au conseil d'administration, allons-nous rencontrer Amanda et son
occasion Je suis sous le capot, tu fumes de l'argent
à Amanda Canada une demi-Jamaïque  qui
forme un moteur  un accord,
nous avons besoin du genre de leadership que
Latini Nakata et Akane
cogito et dans un campus MD maintenant, nous avons besoin
d'une deuxième maison et
la réception économique empêche la mémoire et l'
épinet sait où nous allons avoir besoin de
tout le monde bouche bée et et  euh tellement d'argent que j'ai
puni nabi pourrait être un manone et
umber bash kiddo
ils ont rencontré une balise de tour de chienne garena mon
gaza moi nous c'est de mauvaise qualité je reçois mr.  rondelle
je crois Nina pas de gros chat kuda une
information mec de la carte SD Cohen slating
go tip of the Yankee Vogelsong munitions in
by vote for people who look
you was par exemple web dénarnaud of the now any say
and in ninety and two times plaidor
the exact same  le poisson ternit Amanda
Medusa qu'elle porte en 2015 la destination exacte
maintenant allez Medora merde nonon mana bien sûr
ils vont y mettre fin le nouveau
maître ninja est allé bien arrête allez ouais
judoka da c'est quarante secondes pour chaque
chef nommé le national a bavardé sur
leur  nigga nigga nommé la page nationale de
remerciement meegwetch un diamant de kike
et la foule mondiale le candidat le
mis en évidence par le genre de débat en
cours à ce stade et la Russie cool comment
nous avançons
la réalité est que les Canadiens obtiennent une
éducation canadienne pour nos enfants  leur travail affirmant l'
argent banaji York et aronia Johnny
Bishop cool inflige des amendes aux
Canadiens autour de l'homme Pete Amanda mur d'accord
et gagne des revenus qui continuent de
dominer ici
unde  Il y a quelques mois, Mon Pere,
un médecin du coin de tangage chez Cornell
, l'homme était en fait le garni
gaddama était dans une monarchie, je veux dire quoi
encore, je vérifie Aronia un mois, Peter,
j'adore Dieu,
c'est l'équivalent d'un homme instruit
tous les trois ans comme la population.  de
la Nouvelle-Écosse dans le cornichon de la Nouvelle-Écosse il y a
une minute supplémentaire sur leur bateau
boom tout pour l'émigration massive je peux
annamund Peter c'est un peu un peu si
le Ghana Hamas le seul pays un homme
Peter
inugami Amanda un trois Noguchi Amina
beau pouce alors et ça  vient le Kedah
Madame Mina et ensuite la
conservatrice stupide obtient ce cerca éclatant
du séminaire au plus grand d'entre nous
judoka Donna finissant le puits sur ma
procédure pénale vous fermant
les enquêtes parlementaires
Mandana et non le concert de mod allait
Maga nous obtenons un bronzage  Indonésie et donne
un coup de pied à la Monda quelque chose que je voudrais que
tu fasses pousser la vérité dis-moi que je l'ai fait
quand j'ai dit que doub attendait que ce garçon
ne s'applique pas à toi Je suis Ma  rgay quand
ils sont bien ajustés, c'est la norme pour les
Canadiens Kanani les amène sur
le Web d'Air Canada Nana à faire tous les
jours Nina n'a pas il y a des années pour donner de bonnes
choses, vous ne pouvez pas en dire un contrairement à la
vision Amanda aronia des allégements fiscaux qui
aident les gens qui  faire de la cannelle et les mettre
fin quatre cent mille dollars par
an de plus que quelqu'un qui en fait de nouveaux, vous
devez travailler Joanie et Amanda ouais
cinquante mille personnes avec un manda au
moins vos débiteurs de Kosta Cahuenga Ana est
une victoire Amanda Amazon dans des hommes armés pita arrêtez
la mise à jour akivasha La
plate-forme Sonya est venue  des semaines à indica
quoi
non non la clé sur la mention aller à la mienne la
mienne pourrait être des gens que vous
choisissez comme ça pour la cachette pour
enfant sont Jean et min war tu vas
travailler à nouveau Dennis Asha a choisi Aaron ton
honneur d'
accord toi  partager Kodama maintenant va nous finir
d'accord moi pas d'option pas de clé sur go window
coalition Asha boyish ensemble cornée dans
la et Amanda Hockey Academy noir
Canadiens dominant dans son école détrempé
aller sur th  e silken et ananna
pas brûler et okyun j'ai été connu ed
le Walkman doit assurer Trudeau kiddo
pas mon habitude porte déjeuner dans le Lord walk
Canadiens échidné John Swinney homme allez dans
votre oreille puis finissez-les cette porte
plus venez sur Peter pas  nids de wigwam
Bunge à l'homme non Lunia Peter, ils peuvent
coûter des centaines de dollars
canadiens par mois de marche quand un mois mais Jésus,
nous allons économiser de l'argent aux familles, je sais
quoi même si elle ne marche pas avec toi,
Eddie un mois jetée pour obtenir un navire  marchez
ce Shh encore
Sonya ces énergies c'est votre garçon
aujourd'hui était quand vous êtes des familles plus claires
au moins trouvez un Endon
puis le plus d'argent des impôts P adulte d'un
Jessop lundi en haut Bishop Bishop
Bishop j'ai donné que le Bunge au-dessus de
Gershwin  le Doughboy à ça et ils ont
fouetté un écrou se connecter nous pensons que nous
allons rejoindre le Yémen quand ce cadet comme
votre lame nous avons besoin d'un lundi pas marié
Don Maddie a donné de l'argent parce qu'un lundi
mes agriculteurs pharmacare penology
menthe être fait et nous a donné  un
potard accrocheur Jonas dans le Nokia one Baba mamas
dans signifier leur gamin j'ai honte Mandel ou
une clé lundi lundi c'est aronia c'est
comme ça c'était logique
je crois me souvenir que mr.  Sharif au début
de la course et Acadia mr.  le caissier et je
veux parler au nom de trois mille quatre
cents innocents qui n'ont rien fait de
mal quand monsieur essaie de le finir
et je vais cynisme que d'accord ce que vous êtes
le tireur kadar les gens honnêtes jouent
cette vieille carte si vous vous entraînez à l'immersion dans
un  min du Nam le gnomon P trois
mille quatre cents personnes n'ont
rien fait 3400 mois payés finissent maintenant de
retour en un seul morceau
et il a chanté Internet cette idée n'est jamais
une excuse pour Halloween aller dijanna
dijanna jambe étaient-ils aller chercher la
pizza de l'homme Mun be  il a abusé du pouvoir de
leur bureau pour récompenser leurs amis et
punir la semaine, les gagner ensuite et dans
chaque manière cou MMO, puis dans chaque tombe
et aller qui est en plein essor sachant que le
jeu mod God doit être
gah nous allons vous membre hé je suis  dans
le plus minoen de cette époque et du
Pakistan, puis de mon ouverture meg
whitman pic Je suis Susan Delacorte
du Toronto Star bien Susan Delacorte
condition à travers le Toronto Star n'a pas été
un long mod de guerre choisi par dr au hasard  aw
avec ma question au chef conservateur
Andrew Shearer, vous ne comprenez tout simplement pas ce que
vous voulez dire, M. Shearer, vous avez dit qu'un
gouvernement conservateur se concentrerait sur
des choses pratiques de manière mature et
plus aimable, ce que nous allons apprendre à nouveau
personne pour finir  Novick
ok pas de truc gay whoa ça va s'adapter
et obtenir le consentement des peuples
autochtones sur chaque eau pour gagner une prise
avec frapper à la porte qui n'est pas une grande
porte de boucher bien merci beaucoup
chien comme je pensais 12 réserves des Premières Nations
dans son écriture je comprends  l'
importance de Chenega sait faire
longtemps il n'y a pas de Beckett pas un imbécile et
frapper les jeunes Canadiens pour participer à
l'économie qui est vraiment la clé et la
femme de Keith Saunders pour faire bien pas
étonnant qu'il n'y ait pas grand pour Devon je vais bien
pas plus par porte  sur les préoccupations des enfants en
veillant à ce qu'un cabinet des ministres
responsable spécifiquement du bus avec ou de
Nanako sous la porte nanak ait mal géré la
clé de voûte sur le parcours un kevin ik quand
le mur me kimochi c  'Mon look pipeline,
nous nous assurerons que sa dynamique
est plus que simplement cocher une case et
écouter les préoccupations, c'est en fait vous
savez quand ils étaient, il n'était pas d'accord non,
nous savons qu'ils savent
juste que le mode noggin de la tomate arrête quand
Donna d'accord  / Knox s'affaiblissant dans le démotique
Scott à Amishman,
elle ne coupera pas le fond oh qu'il y
avait aussi un devoir de consultation sur le
gouvernement Harper et ils guérissent et
Donna fume mr.  président
Dunham nous quelle caboche monotone
doit entrer en vigueur dans ce
pays je sais que vous les Nations Unies pouvez
tous faire la guerre comment se concentrer d'accord non pas
que nous ne pouvons pas Morton et ensuite cela n'a
pas été vu jusqu'à ce que nous les mettions d'accord
avec  nous non mais c'est aussi une attaque de panique qui se
passe sur l'équipement dans ce pénis Novick
nous avons soudainement ce que vous voulez que ces
projets passent à Harlan guqin
- vous allez arrêter de travailler sur des manœuvres d'
éjection ou rencontrer le fait que notre
gouvernement a commis des actes  qui étaient
imprudents et volontaires dans l'incendie criminel du virus
et même je continue à regarder même un
cri émis un doc tu dois vouloir punir
parti nous devenons comme des fourmis Novick
je nous ai eu un chien donc pas de kimochi nous les
gens normaux me regardons même d'accord avec  eux à
chibok vous voyez M. Shearer que vous
vouliez shaggy bien sûr les juridictions
ne viennent pas à mochi Linda Cooper chaotique
accro moi elle reviendrait Peter pour faire
Montauk elle ne coupera pas sur sa traduction
Je suis désolé Nick c'est un pipeline tu
ne le fais pas  craindre l'idée d'exproprier des
territoires appartenant à des provinces et
dire que j'étais Peter bas sur Montauk
Chili un codon au-dessus de la fosse Tianjin
veux plus de chaîne d'accord vérifier mijo mijo
qu'est-ce qu'elle devrait boîtes Wade veut que nous soyons
la guerre Robyn Massey notion kid et ça
kechi Québec  de l'eau ensemble d'accord non non
quelque chose sur ce sujet et comme
s'écarter du chemin pour qu'il puisse y avoir un
espace géographique où de grands projets puissent
être construits à nouveau, y compris le Québec, vous
savez Michael mando ce que vous êtes normalement
docile malade ok Washington est un cuisinier de poulet
soit Michael  nya nous ne possédons pas sous un seul
soin l'énergie des États-Unis j'ai
fait mon choix
je crois que le Québec tu sais si tu connais
le Québec pour bouger sur le roi fera la
pétition juive non Tom sur celle sur le
kazakh j'ai fait mon choix  Monsieur.  Basham
tu l'as fait et Québec fera c'est
mr.  Bernier je vous rappelle que cela
respecte les droits des autochtones et je parle de
Donna je veux les regarder pas dans ma
compétition Anishinabe faites une blague merci
nous nous souvenons tous de dix ans de Stephen
Harper qui n'a pas respecté les
droits des autochtones n'était pas génial sur le cœur  oublie
plus je ne donnerais plus assis à
nouveau sous le national nous lui donnons un bon
hockey de poulet ma elle ne peut que chanter c'est
ton jeton ce n'est pas grand le pas de changement
notre [ __ ] nigga nous avons vu mec nous ne sommes pas dans l'
esprit ce sera à peu près pareil  un gentil
Novick pas grand-chose partagez-moi avec l'
oeuf coqueluche faisait des peuples indigènes burger
alors ce gouvernement est l'un de
vos électeurs a M. Shearer c'est
vrai il est venu vous savez super
veilleur de jour je n'ai rien à apprendre de
mr.  Trudeau qui a tiré le poulet au gingembre
sur mon poème sur Trudeau et vous l'avez
renvoyée quand elle l'a fait et vous voulez gêner
sa cour on m'a dit de partir et j'ai
jeté un coup d'œil rapide et beaucoup de choses sur le gros
doudou de squatter ne sont pas sur des
cristaux de cosmonaute dans sera  avec dr.  dîner en
acceptant le fait que je vais être
attaqué pour ne pas avoir construit de pipelines à partir du
son et pour avoir construit des pipelines
pour la construction de pipelines dans tout le
pays par le secteur privé, mais en
même temps, elle pensait que nous devrions suivre
Amanda, elle a acheté du coton, nous devrions  joignez-
vous ici c'est plus sécuritaire de transporter tout en
gaz par pipelines que par trains mais
en même temps le gouvernement du Québec a dit
qu'il n'y a pas de poisson Médina Québec hommes
sur le Xénon de paiement du Québec dans ou
elle-va mego on a cuisiné pourquoi aller chercher  arroser
chaque semaine une femme plus forte la virgule Y
pas un malcolm opiacé pas Tkaczyk ok
on va éplucher vision McQueen sur gâteau mais
tu n'as pas le courage d'utiliser une
contribution pour être sûr qu'on aura des
pipelines dans ce pays pour le  l'unité
de notre pays j'essaie d'identifier le
potentiel du film lancer dans le montage xg1 Scott
machina gagner la distinction alimentaire économique
et marché Nikita entrant dans la courbe
tu n'es pas mort dans l'un des MIT est assez
enthousiaste beaucoup pleure plus de paix  il
vaut mieux prendre de l'énergie de l'ouest du
Canada que pétrolier après pétrolier un
pétrole étranger qui remonte le st.  Lawrence
ou le pétrole et le gaz venant de la question de Donald,
vous savez novanet non Armando Megan vos
hanches se serrent et maman et chanceux le
gouvernement du Tribunal des droits de la personne du Canada et
m.  Les droits de l'homme du gouvernement Trudeau ont fait
preuve de discrimination imprudente, il
est descendu, c'est une femme doc harperman ou le
gouvernement Trudeau Chino bogey no miss
Robin on - tu veux me donner une
caboche honnête maintenant, il vient juste de mr mental.  Trudeau, il
voulait se battre dur pour maintenir le niveau SNC
, puis je cuisinerai bizarrement quand Abbasid sur le
manomètre Basha
reviendra comment quelqu'un pourrait-il faire huyn Majo
ne pas être ennuyé mundo d'énormes ramifications pour
plusieurs aspects de la façon dont le
gouvernement fédéral fournit des services aux
autochtones  Les Canadiens, je ne sais même pas à
qui ils parleront à Monda La
déclaration des Nations Unies sur le travail érotique des droits de l'homme
, oh je ne suis pas d'accord bien sûr, mais je
veux parler d'une autre, elle sait
que nous parlons de Donegal, il n'y a pas
de Monica Rosen obtenir un négatif partiel
sur le mercure ne dit pas merci pour
votre don c'est qu'elle est fausse vivant
avec un empoisonnement au mercure parce que c'est une
sorte de fraude du Premier ministre fait ça
quand ce n'est pas non voulu souhaite que
nous connaissions tous les deux Donald à Londres et
Bastion à Washington nous avons un  question
d'un membre de l'auditoire ici à gatineau
Natasha Bedi allez-y - de vous vous
n'avez pas de fin mais une assez bonne Première
Nation ma question est qu'il y avait une
explication tangibl  e provinces et
territoires non enregistrés pas un faire un
acrostiche une fenêtre Quito conductance
Novick avec laquelle les évêques pseudo et miquelon
cobweb ne savent même pas juger
pas de changement Wilk démence Bostick sur ces
eaux pour gagner en me faisant plus gentil
ce que tu veux
dans les disparus  et assassiné des
femmes autochtones même je ne les battrai pas ce que Nam
un bon moment, y compris quand l'Oklahoma
sera atteint de démence boss poussin également nous soutenons la
préservation intime de la dengue un doc
fera ce qu'il peut pour empêcher certaines d'entre
elles sont les langues qui risquent
de  Montague ce n'est pas possible avec moi
mes coins ou maintenant envoyez-le ou non nous
ne parlions pas et cela ne se passait pas
sur la crème allemande faite sur cela
laisse beaucoup d'incertitude sur ce
que cela signifie et il y en a gros et nous détestons
le Ming Amanda Tommy un degré quel
esprit allez le regarder vous obtenez une punition
ne m'a pas fait venir ma fille
Desmond sur une question extrêmement importante
et les verts à travers le pays êtes-vous
besoin d'un à Dortmund seul d'
accord mariage il doit être amené à
venir non et sans armes sous United et les
déclarations Kaka pensait que nous étions sur Ming
nous étions nous n'essayions pas d'acheter
quoi que ce soit non ce n'est pas grand la reine l'
infirme à Rhonda besoin d'un don  'pas même euh ce n'est
pas très bien je ne suis pas une telle femme
sagasta Queen of Kanagawa brisant la
justice il est aussi Jinky fils de skip je
pensais que c'était canal pour empirer je
crois en j'ai passé les plus beaux
moments de cette campagne avec des gens
de  les Premières Nations ne savent jamais à qui
vous parliez c'est pas moyen commandant
nous faisons moment de nation le Québec est une
nation et une nation ne met pas c'est sa
culture sa langue son héritage dans les
extrémités d'une autre nation d'accord belle encre
pas de poche de xénon nous  savent qu'ils remarquent
qu'il possédait ou tannoy nano un peu gansito
ne voit pas d'optique CinemaScope
rapide à une heure peut un gecko
Arnie dit quoi oh arrête d'arrêter pas
vu sur Aquino devient bruyant Oh merci
Natasha pour ta question, nous avons
avancé sur Russi  une langue neiguan
désarmement génial faisons-nous un
monument pour obtenir le jeu d'un
avis de [ __ ] et nous sommes sur la bonne voie pour
latosha
Osment rien de nouveau Joseph tu sais
ce qui se passe et défait le poisson et le
joshing il y a oui les enfants doivent être
indemnisés et nous deviendrons  pour les
sauver, mais nous avons également été encouragés
à venir sur Tuvok quand nous devrions y aller,
nous voulons dire un long téléphone de canard, vous tuez tous des
flics si je devais commenter avec les
détenteurs de toner McConnell des rétrécissements herbeux dorés sur vous savez nous  sont multi-traitement
général s'en aller d'accord
première nation ils soutiennent tous le statu
quo mais le système est rompu
pour savoir que le Montana va peut-être aller tremper
le Slovaque va essayer de mettre en œuvre Nina -
venez rencontrer Carmen de Sueno nage aucun
témoin un flic était  't in the snow big nous
pourrions parler de notre église pas d'
agression cynique quand et d'accord aucune
pensée je pensais que nous femme sommes morts Ahmad
PCM le calme nous ne sommes pas quand et encore
pas recevoir un bouton psy clignotant
annoncé les canyons
vraiment, c'est une question de respect et de
dignité, pas dans la mienne, ce ne sera pas un homme et l'
une des premières choses que nous ferions ne
serait pas de poursuivre les enfants autochtones en justice
et de contester une décision qui dit qu'ils
ont été délibérément et imprudemment
discriminés, nous ne le ferions pas  faites
ça bien dans un tocino inverse
nous qui nous mettons sur notre dit mauvais
commando mondo qui est capable de faire parmi Pokemon
ce qui confirme que l'un de nos hommes veut l'
immigration donnez-lui un
logement Hockman un logement de bonne qualité
quand nous femme nous ne devrions pas aller à Nick
quand  un nigga nous pouvons oh mon dieu
Kimiko non pour un autre débat de leader à leader
sur n'importe quel sujet menant celui-ci
sera bien le cheval du Parti vert en ce
moment trop longtemps qui suis un chien
monsieur monsieur méga montre le mantra ne faisons pas
face  c'est en ce moment les peuples autochtones de
l'Assemblée des Premières Nations
nous disent leur préoccupation numéro un
c'est l'urgence climatique et nous ne
voulons pas que la cathode National Baker nous
conduise les Premières Nations végétaliennes ou Montes
envoie à nouveau megawa  tt Montes de Oca
protecteurs de documents femme Taklamakan
Amanda prendra ma conversation avec moi Connor
salut Baba Tahsin Pune livre nous mélangeons la
mère de l'œuf nous savons qu'Amanda veut dire qu'ils ne veulent
pas être un poulet seulement allé sur une matzo Jack
Walsh beaucoup de guerre pourquoi ne pas continuer à émettre un
le gardien Judaica se trompe parce que je joue
toujours sur le compromis même un nouvel
incendie criminel d'étang donné sur la tequila à Boston sur
le plastique est nécrotique nous voulons que ces
aquatiques la plupart des Canadiens soient mieux lotis 80
pour cent des Canadiens sont mieux lotis avec un
prix sur la pollution qu'ils ne le feront  être
quand il déchire notre changement climatique s'il
devait former le gouvernement après cette
élection, nous continuerons le grand
concert de Shin non Mike Ross peut se demander si nous savons
qui ne sont pas venus parce que oh poisson nous
entrerons et Nina entrera et frappera un
jeune garçon  va aller devenir chaotique quand
nous reviendrons sur le - vu
qu'ils doivent me voir mère geckskin point
carter Anoka peut maintenant commencer
à rater le patron du Minnesota
à l'échec c'est pourquoi c'est si faisable et
réalisable parce que ce n'est pas le cas  faire ce que
le GIEC dit que nous devons faire et encore mélanger s
savoir et même venir au gouvernement de Cindy
sohcahtoa seul à West Lake Mendota
skier une semaine sur le gâteau de recherche optique optique mais
pas de comité sur 7x sur l'incitation des enfants de Ianoukovitch
à investir à Montauk pour
exhorter même pour l'instant  ne mélange pas Monda
lutte contre le changement climatique protège l'
environnement et crée une étincelle c'était
humain même en le frappant je suis debout dans
tu connais une image c'mon kiddo game over
complètement faux
et juste parce que tu dis quelque chose encore
et encore et encore  ne le rend pas
vrai, il y a une puce Harbhajan Kadeem mundo
et des fourmis mères éduquées Watauga mando
Manorama savent que nous allons sur
la neige chocolat chaud xf inss fumée d'
accord je serai la portée du kid
mondo bounce les femmes ne sont pas  les femmes sont
assez bizarres, elles parlaient depuis qu'Austin a
libéré de l'eau aujourd'hui et mr.  nier qu'il
existe une autre option
et là-bas deuxième d'accord quand je
demande à mr.  Delaney ou 39 le concept
allez-vous sortir nigga non non allez,
regardez-moi quand l'argent nominal des femmes
m'a donné me donne pas ouvert et Oh Nandu
Nandu peut il y a plus de méga cosmique quitter
emoji et vérifier un marché de Commons je
ne Je ne pense pas que ce sera sur J&L Québec et
le fait que vous souteniez un
projet qui fait exploser une plus grande partie du
budget carbone contre la volonté de plusieurs,
ce n'est même pas un accord,
puis rouvrez ce qui n'est pas beaucoup moins cher.
Lawrence que pensez-vous de cette
idée d'une péréquation basée sur le gammon
à tashika na na shop we Chicago a et
ceux qui sont sous la moyenne des
émissions obtiennent l'argent à Davis pour l'
option boondock n'est pas communiste vérifie-
moi au-dessus de la poche à eau qui lorgne  condos
autour de la chaîne dodge modern alors vérifiez-
moi sur le tofu négatif à peu près quand un
Nagano Gotama baduk un midi Guan le
début des régimes épidémiques Peter me
manquait Nina Gordon
[Musique]
bonjour je suis Donna congélateur Bonjour Donna
cadre dans Globo news
Mon P  vers le bas et lancez-vous sur le Yémen être
sombre dans une fin ensemble officiellement un
PETA ergonomique
hungee adopter je vous ai donné qui ne nous a pas largués
sur cela faites-le euh Kodama deux
billions de dollars de dette des ménages
Canadiens deux billions de gentils billions de
bien elle pourrait  ont souvent un lundi
il y a un chien Ratana devenu gaga qui spamme un
junior qui fait le moka veux pas
botter un de bunda voyez-vous dans le vous
nishan il suce ils savent se faire pas
comme un ouais j'ai besoin d'un lundi Peter wi  gwam
leur McGwire se lance dans un
cadet Arnie des Pyrénées mélangez-les le
Colonia dijanna mezzanine gun kiddo
kiddo le moyen d'apporter plus d'
initiative de service public avec leur et Madame
Monday aronia a bonala G à une bonne part
génome entier notre concert méga méga discuter
voir je  ne veux pas dire une fin, je suis ils la
rassemblent ouais je devrais augmenter cet
ozone ouais bien sûr ce qu'ils ont fait de toi
et puis la vignette au
pourcentage de base pur avec ça mr.  NASA qu'un
million de Kaboul l'économie actuelle dans laquelle je
suis et je suis l'esclave Giga d'accord
idéologiquement équilibré les livres mais en
ce moment nous pensons que nous connaissons le nom alors obtenez l'
homme P de usted owatta gay lasagna miss
make it out et je pourrais être  vraiment une mauvaise
idée d'emprunter pour le vivre Nina nominal
un autre hein
- quand dans le vent et les services du Dharma
aux gens qui le souhaitent
Enochian je suis sous une action aucun enfant ne m'a dit que
je suis sous AB au milieu de deja tu sais l'
apporter  tous sur le sol à propos de um big Amanda
apporte de l'argent au gouvernement
Amanda net auroria s'ils deviennent fragiles
femme nous étions de ces géants du
web discernés alors venez lundi Dina
ils iraient là-bas et ils sont encore partis
Amazon Google Facebook  dans un non et un
milliard peut aller nous avons besoin d'une Russie bon
après-midi Bob du midi ke kanaka da
cunha mr.  tirez bien bonne participation il y a un
mois à ma destination sur ce pas de terre
et je suis ce gamin que nous pouvons l'obtenir Je le
transmets un lundi le lob sur leur air sain
ne peut pas vous avoir à nouveau mr.  Trudeau
Kedah obtenir un lundi aronia a exigé un
bon garçon Amanda fou ou a vu des gens du jour
que Nestor
Amanda mettre à jour et puis non il est le
gagnant
jeune soldat au noyau mille je ne peux
pas du tout je suis sous maintenant comment puis-je me faire à
nouveau  alors qu'ils devraient connaître un homme Peeta
la nageuse aronia Amanda basic million
s'est fait kidnapper réduire la pauvreté dépassant tous les
objectifs qu'on avait même sur les pauvres
descendre le magazine de Saussure
nous faire de la luge nous allons dans le bus j'y vais je
parie que tu fais sur  le double au fait
et je suis sûr qu'un certain nombre d'autres leaders
sur scène le partagent nous ne pouvons pas dîner
Amanda oh allez nous pouvons y aller j'étais un
ouais
mec Peter Anisha maman hezonia inaudible
Mazda gagne maman sous l'équipement canadien coup
sur  Lundi où ils
manquaient, je pense que disent-ils La
cuisine de Mishka a terminé North Oakland pourquoi
vous devriez chien est-elle pensée débat
là-bas à la place ils WAP puis une
Amanda je suis Maggie vous gagnez soixante milliards de
dollars Midna milliard d'aronia Baba
téléphérique nous  un  une autre fois d'accord mais c'était
secret mais non pas de clé quand une arme à feu
sauriez-vous que pas Abby milliard avec le
vent peut faire un aronia abinell G mais
maintenant agate Shipman sur l'élément bêta son
école K Donna
je suis la navette une fin et Amanda comme sur
le Nokia dont nous avons besoin pour obtenir ce dr.  Sonya
the National Grid sans aucun doute la
version Jean un roi qui tire Amanda King un
Canada dans lequel je suis à la fin Amanda une province que je
ne peux pas obtenir ne peut pas bénéficier de la dérive canadienne sur les
subventions d'Amanda est-ce que nous formons une bonne
merde sur ma version donc l'argent n'a pas de clé
mr.  dominos puants mission particulière
la discussion vers les soins de santé je
pense que je suis à moi et Amanda sont confortables et
et euh l'amazone gommeuse dans le pays de Dieu
Ghani et le fait monter les commandants Mishka
puis orné le gâteau oh non
nous sommes dans le singe maintenant  parce qu'elle était
gênée qu'elle aime un homme ninja
dénudé aller dans la boîte
briser un garçon de la campagne, vous êtes
prêt à le faire, mais le problème
est mr.  Truman à la frontière
bien quand le dîner Garwin la fenêtre Giada
il y a un Amish kaki et à
Regina et d'accord quand l'homme Peter
ils ont essoufflé à cause des mêmes évadés
et euh pourriture heya heya neros sur une
cuisine automnale escy anak et
anandam la mezzanine gammas  nom de fille et Peeta
un aki kawaii encore une fois je suis dans une endémie
assure nager sur PT quoi voir et puis
puis-je avoir l'esprit de tenir l'
autre Montgomery va euh Mishka gear
puis dans ma bière ce qu'il y a et la
question est pourrait obtenir  Quinn Montebello,
bien sûr, je suis dans Depok toute la
dette du ménage dans le droit Amanda wigwam
là-bas avec le sel qui est celui pour
qu'ils puissent obtenir un nom d'ego et que le
Canadien tue ce que le gagnant a certainement
sauté à bord,
nous allons ramener le  chiliens
signifie celui pour Nia la peur de l'homme des cavernes
est de créer un crédit d'impôt sur l'énergie pour
rendre le bus ou le train plus
abordable ainsi que nous allons aider à
lutter contre le
crédit d'impôt pour la rénovation domiciliaire verte Oh  Le
hamac à clé George au crédit mettra que nous avons
fouetté et fouetté et amené l'homme et
Dieu là-haut pour obtenir de la merde et le coronium
sous le chien de garde sur Hennigan
quand cela a entendu ou de menthe Amanda King
et moi possédons l'évier mr.  Schurr nous avons besoin d'une
devise nous et c'est dans la femme lundi
est le pays est engagé un roi
dans ce jeu atomiseur et lundi dans n'importe quel
parti lui et maintenant la façon dont la clinique
Sonia homme péda ensemble ouvert a
marché dans un pick up pick
ramasser ramasser cet enfant cet ananda Monda lundi
leur mois Territoire du Nord-Ouest kiddo
sait que nous pensons que je fais un jeu d"enfant
Scott Morrison Kidani Morrison magicien
parce que lundi soir Yellowknife
crise croissante de l"inégalité des revenus et de l"
abordabilité au Canada Je veux sortir avec
cette connaissance aronia Amanda
Canada Porsche Yellowknife kid Je pourrais
ils veulent un regard sur le fait qu'au fil
des ans, l'écart qui s'est niché en eux lorsque
le lundi doit naître Annie
Ghani et le diamant d'or du jardinier se
taisent, puis la désertion d'Amanda Oh Julia est
fausse, cela signifie également qu'ils  ne pas et
dans le génome comme dans l'argent de guerre loin
des Canadiens qui en ont le plus besoin
et était un candidat peut un simin canadien
et eux pour obtenir l'aronia lundi soif si
ils ont un statut spécial et n'ont pas
à payer leur amino puis la
première mesure mr.  Larson Kedah net Tom Kedah
disant des choses fausses à la fin des temps
est votre méchant garçon magicien à Peggy
elle j'avant maintenant la guerre Le gouvernement fédéral du Texas
devait respecter ich bin dans le temps
fédéral non Derrick McKey cela
coûterait moins cher maha nigga Bunge l'aronia
Amanda a  Le Québec
encore et l'unité sous le Johnny Walker
est de retour et les provinces manda a Québec a les
provinces l'argent devrait être donné aux
provinces au Québec parce que c'est le Québec
minhwa pendant ce temps je suis sur l'aronia au chez
Amanda Québec
mr.  Trudeau pour vous, la question concerne
Trudeau Kadam, une Acura manquante,
l'homme non Anishinabe Peter,
je pense que je suppose que Johnny, je pourrais
mourir avant Annie a un méchant minhwa dans
le magasin, ils vont faire
augmenter leur aronia de natation  l'argent le
sol dans leur Guarnere minhwa Tiger hors
de la pauvreté et l'objectif de 10 000 pour les
enfants de moins d'un jour de base nigga a vu un peu
pas de G 75 nous nous assurons qu'ils vont bien
quand Xena remue les dettes d'un étudiant en
ne me faisant pas le laver  bien que nous soyons
en soumission et sur un millier de
personnes jusqu'à Jimmy pépin mr.  trudeau m.
Bernier kid ah je pense que cela sous-tend
notre discussion sur ce qui est important
pour les Canadiens que nous sommes quand un ennemi connu
andum Kotaku dit sur la scène euh
économique Peter lavez-le sans
aile que le nokia a connu et milliard
kiddo elle est la seule promesse qu'ils
font  épicatéchine
PC rien sauf équilibrer le budget
et après que nous sommes des femmes, la MA Emma
va dans un mr plus pur maintenant.  Bernier
Kedah Je veux rencontrer Scott
Kedarnath, il y a aussi une énorme
inégalité de richesse et ce ne sont pas seulement je veux dire
à la fin de l'Asie quand ceux qui sont au
sommet ne paient pas leur juste Amin qui va
là-bas avec le pourboire quand ça fait
mal aux familles province en  soins signifie que nous
n'avons pas votre réseau de diamants bien que le
marché bien sûr mr.  Chu n'aime pas
parler d'un jeu agréable et je mr.  Rose
Trudeau domina, il a donné 14 milliards de
dollars à l'affirmation la plus riche près
du milliard de windom, donnez-moi l'argent, je suis
Bobby, allez Peter avec, nous devrions
savoir que nous allons tous nous accrocher dans un instant
mrs.  nah peut-être que nous y arrivons étant un geek
au
souhait de Jimmy mr.  Killa M.  Sutro s'est
encore trompé sur les faits
mr.  trudeau kid cette fille nous allons rire
beaucoup mieux pour le revenu moyen contient
que sa proposition et il pense que
certaines personnes regardent pour obtenir de la manne de lasagne
pour lui l'Autriche de la nation leur
mur s'impatientent l'optin et obtiennent ceux de
votre dîner nabab près de ne pas marcher pas de
chanter  il y a une maman au Bunge baba
dit grandir et se développer et offrir les types
d'opportunités aux poissons de jeu qui ont
des revenus beaucoup plus élevés, je veux dire sur eux, ils obtiennent euh
les mods en bonnes parts seulement un démocrate
protégeant les personnes qui ont hérité de
fonds fiduciaires nous prendrons un  différent un
vairon et ils n'ont pas de fonds fiduciaires les
entrepreneurs ont le soutien dont ils ont besoin
pour grandir et réussir je devrais savoir min
et puis eux d'accord kenny west encore mr.
Trudeau sort et bloque à l'exigence
Badal squad squad the big ol gamma Je
pourrais peut-être secouer une
base de péréquation fédérale à ce que je sois nan une nan
province nous garde dans un sentiment de base n'importe quelle
mère faite par l'enfant sur le système fédéral
où  la richesse est partagée, vous avez fait référence
à la note de service et un
premier ministre de Julia Lago a dit qu'il voulait que nous
jouions en Premier League à ce niveau autoritaire
êtes-vous d'accord avec cela et s'ils sont
enthousiastes na de muro de mods Irwin Anna
Amanda au Canada le très  système appelé
péréquation que Tom Guetta
Nicky raisonne comme des moyens d'analyser je devrais
connaître l'initiation nationale quelque chose d'
autre qui le remplacerait progressivement
ou un homme P jusqu'à un membre les provinces du milieu
donnent que vous pourriez chier ou
un membre junior revenir Xena sont
Ning manda  un roi un Canada l'utilisent
comme une menace sur le Québec comme je vais un homme
de Jésus ne veut pas être le Québec un
passage pour cette huile à travers leur
territoire parce qu'ils étaient OG ne peut pas être
fait Amanda ou ils ne sont pas le
w  sans aucun changement de Constitution aller dans
la réforme de la Constitution dans la lutte contre le
changement climatique Muscadet que le livre shui a
reçu de l'argent miji donnant un fort
encouragement je veux dire sur et les
décidant anglais mr.  Blackie de base bon
une chienne coincée dans un mois canadien
bon nous avons besoin de leur province oui un
système parfait mais c'est une étoile aile sur
l'opportunité à travers le Canada continue l'
agonie dans notre monarchie avec un sperme
anglais Onagawa quelque chose qui continue
de lier cela arrive dans  et euh être
Serena pour créer des combats entre le Tibet
et doit maîtriser l'enchère c'est un rapide Québec
Canada c'est lundi et dis-moi
quelque chose Oh squash de puce ils y vont
notre budget sur la promenade et
ils pourraient être encore des décennies oh gee
Kijana Beemer  les hommes veulent recommencer
chérie tu as Canadia et Kenny un fils un peu
merdique à la porte gros expéditeur humide
nu sur je veux dire quelle minute à la fin
les là Monte moments d'accord MA j'ai
été le dîner WAP Amanda et moi
désolé je  veux dire sur le faire un garçon wingait
va et aussi au Québec le commandant
pendant ce temps Québec au jour ouvrable monsieur le
jour du ministre c'est tellement important d'avoir
une quête pour avoir une discussion sur la
péréquation je veux dire il y a une académie
et je nous  nt in laissez-moi savoir encore et
encore chérie Anishinabe a fait Luke est allé
lavement naw chienne au ton de la marche fait
signe à un cigare oniy amendement Peeta à
nouveau maintenant puis-je ouvrir Erica Canada I quand
il y a un Becca kidnappé était-je oui maintenant
parce que dans et puis  eux je suis sur vous jouer d'
accord
je veux dire et Enochian nous pouvons construire un
meilleur Canada si nous relevons certains des
défis auxquels les gens sont confrontés l'une
des choses dont nous entendons beaucoup parler au
Québec, nous aurions dû être les miens d'accord
je '  m sous Canada nous travaillons ensemble
Universal my way Amanda et Mishka
pharmacare Kedah lundi ils sont
provinciaux et la même Virginie et
encore ce serait si je suis plus touché par
la gomme et dit la province de
juridiction Amanda un cadavre provincial
je veux dire une endoscopie  sur interférer et
enfreindre dans deux juridictions, nous pouvons avoir des
portes comme un fils Oh Canada
oh ma façon Oh éclaté n'est pas le travail
qui concerne beaucoup de gens Oh
wigwam et je construis des partenariats
en pensant que leur arme est méga je veux dire  Je veux dire
- je veux dire - je suis Jimmy Gretchen M. Shearer
m.  Singh a fait ça quel
but spirituel aujourd'hui Joey cette table dans wadi
ganoub wha Oh Becca Becca Becca a fait
celui um mr.  rougissez quelques minutes qui
continueront de faire pression sur les
contribuables de Kayne en rencontrant davantage et nous sommes
là-haut, les papillons de nuit à nouveau que l'
aronia bien quand Danna souhaite en parler
descendez maintenant rejoignez-vous au moment où la réclamation au
titre du Québec obtient cette chatte alors  nous savons
que si les bateaux pour les députés du bloc québécois le
cube du Mossad profitent du temps
non nous l'avons fait Québec pour être là merde
cadet combien de fois j'y suis encore allé est-ce
que j'ai été un verger le chien pour me promener
dans un Bunge un bunkie get it get  elle
endure la marche l'une sur l'autre
et vous êtes tous les deux à court de temps,
n'écoutez pas un grand pourquoi le bateau devrait-il être une
bonne chose, le gamin de Yellowknife est mort
Nawab que je veux dire, vous les avez glissés sur
ils vont et ce qu'ils gagnent alors  et
lundi, une cause d'Ellen propre à Canada min alors
et plus comme l'Alberta qui a le
défi le plus difficile, je souhaite que l'
ailier de livre de cendres de l'Alberta leur soit bizarre puisque
vos positions précédentes sur le pétrole étaient
assez G boy, je suis au milieu d'un milieu et je
peux  sur le dîner ici Maka  na Nelson
allez ici le diamant que pouvons-nous commander à
dîner d'
autres nous sommes confrontés à une urgence climatique
et une fin
qu'un livre shway Amanda Amanda awawa a akhir
provinces caddesi Monte moi maman ou mon enfant
je suis dans l'énergie
je me demande une chose  allons-nous alors
Lester vous cisailler monsieur part descendez
Amanda Shaw ganoush plus de vent sur une
ville de l'état et construisez mr.  Asha
Parekh dans le mois, nous faisons un truc d'accord de merde
mais vous êtes un collaborateur très proche
mr.  Allen oui mec personne
encore avant-hier a elle nah aller
tuer Donna a dit qu'en français je dois
admettre que tu deviens basique un chien pourrait mr.  Nash
une facture de base nous allons avoir un enfant Donna
cette question est très simple Monsieur non
non non j'ai toujours été très clair sur
cette question nous n'interviendrons pas dans le
procès un ailier esquivant Enochian un
mod impair Gaiman Peter un lundi à  Québec
dijanna la façon dont allez minhwa je suis en quelque
sorte choper un maje comique et en français
c'est très bien qu'est-ce qu'il respecte et
protège les libertés individuelles Sushma gagner
où obtenir cette chatte de Manteca poursuivre
cette da fenêtre - Jean et un pouce  c'est
une victoire et mr.  scherk Adama mon oh mon c'est
la même chose dans un gagnant Giga qui va
obtenir une dévotion gagnante pour mon jeu Tushar
pourrait dire que je suis mort au vent sur un accord
que vous le protégeriez Je sais qu'une
fourmi
va entrer ici que mr.  fait de
cette façon le débat ouvert manque je veux dire
cet homme Pitt Blanchette kedaranatha
signifie qu'ils vont signifier et la Guinée signifie
jeu en eux il n'y a personne qui va je
pense que vous essayez et puis parce
qu'ils n'existent pas vous y allez quand il y a  un
mois peta la réponse
Windigo shaylen c'est notre jogger
Nostromo dans ne poursuivra pas une fenêtre
Jonathas une victoire nous avons défendu la
liberté individuelle été un des droits de l'homme c'était un
Premier ministre conservateur ce problème
à Andaman sur dojaquez tu ne vas pas bien
homme LGBT je  pense que gamin qui pourrait un million de
gamins le gamin que des millions de cadets ont une
position différente sur leur Jonah aller
j'ai été lundi deux clés personnellement
pro-vie c'est un beignet min et une
chatte de taureau que j'ai trompé près du Walkman noir
ils Canadiens un  gamin ils sont pauvres gamin
il y a tu as cette base une décennie
sous l'analyste de l'aile Nicolas et l'inertie
jin.o a commencé à en faire un pendant ce temps au
nikah de monsieur a synchronisé la base à l'
opposé propre que ce que minhwa en face
sur Mosca
oui  h aller au dijanna et le rapide
aller oh alors ils viendront ils sont
tous prêts à avoir peur quand ai-je mon
amendé un dans le jingle il y a à Monica
pourrait être le jour Bunge sur le web qu'un
quiz demander oh c '  mon Kamini garni question
banane Donna
Garwin gay allez-y mr.  Tovar wall
puis mon homme Peter
Sonia et le Quai Walkman PETA et moi
allons travailler avec mr.  chaise m.  Schurr
gamin loin monsieur près près près de l'homme
budget de pointe un autre ce que moi Noah queer
ira dans un secret Ananda va aller s
toboggan ah miss megator comment pourrait-elle
faire ce que nous sommes bons pour aller Attica comment
pourriez-vous obtenir mon cahoteux
[Musique]
salut  tout le monde je suis romarin Barton romarin
Barton je parle de notre nomination
ne devrait pas neiger mundaka assez de neige
était-ce encore quand nous rencontrons Camille Amanda
Brunswick est là et a cette question
Norman du Nouveau-Brunswick d'Omaha - je marche
pourquoi Google salut mon nom est  Britt
Bancroft et je viens de Minton au Nouveau-
Brunswick et je crois que Grant
Crompton est un nouveau projet gratuit et change de patron
et c'est la dernière élection que nous avons eue
avant qu'un point de non-retour ne soit atteint
jusqu'à l'école, nous allons faire connaissance avec Josh en
m'avertissant de continuer  Coach Jia Ming il y a un mois,
rejoignez-moi, allez Roberta, quels
plans concrets chaque dirigeant a-t-il pour s'attaquer aux
grandes entreprises qui polluent notre nouveau
traitement de l'eau schmatta, nous savons que notre stockage
veut que les enfants, jeunes poussins, ne
vérifient pas  pour ne pas prendre d'assaut sous un roi jusqu'à présent c'est
cet accord entre la Californie au
Québec c'est une terre indienne de Californie
Québec Donna entreprises pour baisser le
temps de vérité d'émission et c'était
international nous avons réussi à mahjong
kazoo j'ai eu le privilège de terminer
la négociation d'un tel système  et le
signer et ça devrait avoir de l'importance
ailleurs, nous savons que ça va durer longtemps qui
retournent dans les poches des gens
sans aucun changement une incitation ou non
la solution dunya
nous sommes sur ce que Natasha Chicago est chic comme
mr.  le sang a dit que le Québec et d'autres
provinces comme la Colombie-Britannique ont avancé, mais en
mettant un prix sur la pollution, nous avons
assuré aux hommes québécois sur la Colombie-Britannique, nous le savons - pas de
monsieur
Nikki klaxon sur le pont, je me demande si nous pouvons venir en
Angleterre le choix ce soir Nina - une
femme peut-elle même obtenir  sur cela, nous pourrions
faire de longs
mètres purs 1l d'eau propre sur le
changement climatique Le Canada n'a jamais eu le lendemain
des élections et nous continuerons à faire
plus, nous reconnaissons que nous devons savoir que nous
pourrions faire un jeu de compromis d'accord non
nous  sommes forts, nous devrions être plus jeunes, je vais
garder que tu ruines, je dois regarder le
moment, euh, du travail de DiNapoli, dans la mesure du
possible, nous voulons faire des choses qui sont
possibles pour protéger ou pour la santé ou Nina
Skinner peut s'éloigner n'aura pas besoin de toi pour obtenir l'
homme  avec l'ailier de Robert de Guiche en
coupe Nolan peut éliminer ce que
nous ferons et ils ont également affirmé
être en mesure d'atteindre l'objectif de l'Accord de Paris
ils ne peuvent pas ils doivent imposer
notre décollage je veux l'enthousiasme voir non
il y a un vin McGirt nous voulons que je sois avec
le  mur tu peux  rétrogradez-les Nicholson
baccarat
tout ce qui a donné à nos pensées notre reine
ogimachi est à propos de la question que nous sommes confrontés
à la crise climatique il n'y a aucun
doute sur Google donc pas de bon bain dans
ma promenade
vous pouvez aller simplement connecter des
inondations massives ce qui signifie que les gens Chema Moshe
cornica sont sérieux  la neige s'est mariée ou mais
pas le pouvoir d'accord ce qui ne peut pas les plus gros
pollueurs de son prix et de la pollution
il dit que la conduction est bien pas le
commandant du Raja je voulais Bogota soie
moi d'accord mobile Mac est allé sur un pipeline
Montauk sushi veut être pris sur Miyamoto
non seulement a gagné le totem  de
décor de table Amishman ostrogothique je me retrouve
à nouveau d'accord avec vous mr.  M. Singh.  bien sûr qu'il n'y
avait pas de monsieur synchronisé avec je pouvais regarder
puis-je donner ok la contrebande d'accord regardez-
le ensemble déchirer un vrai plan son
plan s'est avéré échouer il
m'a donné un jeu sur monsieur bien que je
puisse vendre aux enchères dois m'avoir
joint mondo n'obtenez pas de vinaigre d'arbalète un
bœuf à la maison lundi je pourrais être
exempté de sa taxe sur le carbone pendant que
les navetteurs qui travaillent dur chef qui n'est
pas sigmundur qu'en est-il de vous, chefs d'orchestre
et gigas d'Okinawa, parlez-moi, je me demande si
je peux obtenir n'importe quel costume sur la scène
clairement  comprendre que nous sommes confrontés à
une véritable urgence climatique le tournoi
seul c'est juste pas d'amour ailier tournée
réservée faire la guerre ne s'ouvre pas au milieu
karni mata nous frapperons Sonoma le
roi de l'eau envoie-nous ça juste frapper
mère anokhin accord seulement pour s'engager
dans un phénomène quantique ik connu seulement
un degré personne sur la lune l'automne dernier,
le Groupe d'experts international
sur l'évolution du climat des Nations Unies a souligné la nécessité d'
agir rapidement pour limiter davantage United
Nati  ons il pourrait dépasser mundo webqueen
Makana il pourrait chêne certains moi aller Samanta
nessing mundo geeks cock Medina shaggy
hawk
Mandark kinder shaggy nous avons Amanda Gish
jouet dans mijo laver n'est pas romantique
elle veut du code sur Bush peut vouloir ne pas
marcher de poulet seulement donc peut regarder  encore une
fois quand le laveur de vitres sur moi parce
qu'elle doit absolument faire plus et
c'est pourquoi nous faisons des ornements sur Minaj et
doux parmi les saucisses Shing va au-delà
avec la femme ne supporte pas kr il y a
le pénis était quelque chose de supona livre ne
gagnez pas un seul  Lundi pas de liquidation pas
MUX pas moxie frapper à la porte Nate a
fait remarquer que nous n'avons pas dit que vous saviez
ce que le grand hiver Tom Gus non sans
aucun pipeline de produits de ce type dans cette
transition énergétique verte à l'église le 21 août
à midi quand m.  Thomas Rooney en
rejoint également un, ne nous asseyons-nous pas lorsque Curtis
est venu sur Trudeau, nous avons fait le choix
ce soir, est-ce que nous choisissons un gouvernement qui
n'est pas non essentiel - je veux dire, je suis bon juste en
disant
le roi de la saucisse au miel sans commentaire anoxique
nous '  re sur notre dernier pipeline mr.  Bernier à
votre tour de débattre m.  Monsieur.  Bernier
sweet tom est d'accord avec la mesure de la tapenade
mais tu ne pourras pas ruser ils
valent la peine de tourner les mots dans l'image
nissan oh allez jeu Decatur dessus elle
va à chaque tournoi euh regarde le
compromis comment ne pas s'embrasser nous
nous  connais Seto en Malaisie quand une agression pour
lutter contre le changement climatique détruira l'
économie, mais qu'en est-il de toi, je ne veux pas que le
monde
me joint, mère, tout ce que nous ne sommes pas assis sur le
ticket
Iago maintenant sup serait peut-être moi Khan
n'était pas assez de stockage cosmonaute nidification
obtenir un  jeu de construction du plan pour l'
avenir de notre économie si vous ne
construisez pas un plan qui protège l'
environnement et lutte contre le changement climatique
c'est là que vous avez tous les deux
complètement tort
bonne nuit brûleur si vous avez donné l'
impression que vous alliez faire du climat une grande
priorité, mais la réalité est que vous avez fait toutes
ces choses regarder Conan sur Waco
personne Edmondo alors qu'est-ce que ça va prendre
maintenant contre pas Keisha pour aller wom  en dogies de
ne plus te parler tu veux konami
ils étaient un message à la maison veux que Keisha
obtienne la paix nous allons blanc Margate
le mr.singh Les Canadiens pourraient être
surpris de découvrir que votre
plan est de tolérer l'agua en alberta et
la seule façon de le faire  est avec des
subventions fédérales parce qu'il n'y a pas d'
entreprise privée Dean, nous vous donnerons une raffinerie,
nous devrions rejoindre le denim catéchétique
Miccosukee le chanteur mobile obtenir la fenêtre s'asseoir
sur le dessus quand justin trudeau a pris ses fonctions
il y avait trois grands projets de pipeline
prêts à passer sous sa surveillance tout moi
mobile allez  commencer sous assistance respiratoire et
il l'a fait en envoyant 4,5 milliards de
dollars bientôt sur ne pas manger alors elle n'arrêtera pas de
faire de la politique en espèces plus de
bogeys un mouvement efficace Kingman le nous
pas Morton et sur longtemps nous devrions faire un don
ou Dexter elle gagnera '  t coupé tout seul jeune
m'en a pris un alors ce poussin mondo n'est
pas du genre à parler sur des barres de penny vérifiant le
faux rebord de la fenêtre pour votre transport
parce que vous ne croyez pas qu'ils étaient
ccino ccino cci  pas de document d'accord, donc la
gamification et votre plan est de déchirer
le seul plan sérieux de lutte contre le
changement climatique à Tuskegee nous sommes allés ne pas
dépenser plus que l'ouverture pour éviter
des niveaux catastrophiques de réchauffement climatique
nous devons doubler notre objectif actuel nous
devons écouter la science  elle a été lundi
semaine sauter faire nous savons aussi faire
mère depuis un autre moment d'accord les genoux
et l'optique
repousser méga nous l'aimons ou pas la paix
nous allons faire un remix semblable à entendre
parler Oh smack ouais marcher Merci n'est
pas sur la mère elle a gagné '  t couper sur
wondermint manda she not chicken ont été
élus
promettent de ne rien faire sur le changement climatique
et nous avons besoin d'un gouvernement fédéral fort
pour les combattre afin de nous assurer que nous
allons de l'avant en protégeant le futur
déploiement d'emplois de l'objectif de Harper de 30
% d'ici 2030 nous  sont à Montauk toyomi
allez Amanda Harper a abandonné le cadet - non l'un
sur l'autre et il a dit quel objet
objet sous sachons juste que c'est le
pire émetteur de GES oh vous ne le
sauriez même pas  qu'à propos de Koenig facile à gagner,
mais d'abord comment les mélanges savent-ils que le Canada peut
aller maintenant va avoir besoin de mondo les
problèmes internationaux auront préséance sur
la vue d'ensemble du Canada deuxième question
promettez-vous après ce jugement en Colombie-
Britannique de ne jamais essayer de faire
traverser la punition d'accord Beck  ou éduquez moi
condo commando Queensland Oh le commandant a
dit non oh ta chanson sur Pico Beckman
reçois sur Khatami la science médiévale on a
mis en place un processus qui fait mais
ils cuisinent avec pas à Monaco pas de
provinces de la question Okemah pas de
crème mobile Nikita CoV pas à Manik  nous
savons que nous ne le savons pas encore je suis bon pour
qu'ils continuent à aller parler avec plus nous réduisons les
impôts pour les Canadiens nous savons que personne ne
me touche Nando a commencé sur une colonne de condo
connue - Torchic Oh importe sosie
sur le condo neva nagesh Torchic  Windows
game over pure ne peut pas venir à cause du
gain de kana et eux - game over nous
bâillons deux fois pour obtenir un seul
jeu yangchen me sont Bashir était-ce que vous
répondez M. Shearer en premier  tout monsieur
Trudeau, vous semblez être étrangement obsédé
par la politique provinciale, il y a un
poste vacant, je suis sur le National, je n'ai pas fait de
mois de poids seul, merci provincial
, venez le chercher quand ma
nana Canada, votre politique fiscale signifie
que 80% des Canadiens  les familles paient des
impôts plus élevés aujourd'hui que lorsque vous avez quitté
le bureau pour la première fois, une veuve a donné Je n'allais pas
être un tel orignal une femme peut-elle choisir
Anna Kennedy Je vais me vérifier quand le
monde
Wonder Girls poussin Mandakini
rouvrira contre votre impôt  randonnées sur les
Canadiens mr.  Trudeau ouais c'est
ça j'ennuyais ça en direct non j'ai pris un R pour
tous les Canadiens avec une baisse d'impôt universelle
on va ramener le
temps de fitness des enfants mr.  Shiva no whoa Sonia
monte dans la neuvaine Vuitton signifie encore une fois que tu en connais un sur kunkka le jeu d'une chemise pourquoi
tu réduisais les impôts de 50 000 $ pour
plusieurs sur chaque accord euh je ne peux pas
remettre en question le mois de notre loi de régiment sur
chaque pas mentionné notre lavage de chaussettes  gentil
dans l'argent un attrape-chien seulement je
vérifie - attendez le livre vos
hausses d'impôts sur les entrepreneurs des petites entreprises
vous les avez appelés des tricheurs fiscaux là ce
sont les gens de notre communauté non
personne n'a besoin d'une remarque désinvolte bogey
désolé parce que je le vois ici
je pense qu'elle amènera Trudeau
à environ quanta à Gaza j'ai une
suggestion pour vous que diriez-vous de cette idée
qui a été demandée à l'unanimité par
quelque chose qui est dans le grand Québec d'un
seul remboursement d'impôt qui permettrait  à propos
de chaque Nam, c'est qu'il a été mon
mantra le plus actif maintenant d'
homme whoosh énergique qui ne parle jamais de
déclaration de revenus Katonah pour les Québécois oui je suis
le seul parti fédéral incluant avec
tout le tournoi régional du Québec
attaques ouais pops kappa [ __ ] moi jeu d'
aquatique comme votre bien vous avez beaucoup
parlé de réductions d'impôts mais c'est la réalité
, c'est que les Canadiens peuvent me regarder
avec la blessure - qu'en est-il de l'
argent que vous savez - façon de boogie sur les coupes
les coupes dans l'éducation aux soins de santé les
coupes vicieuses pour les personnes les plus
vulnérables de la société l'économie des expéditions de compteurs
peut montage malade anémique j'ai aussi remarqué
non du wiggly vous savez en quelque
sorte sauter une semaine n'est pas ce que vous savez
Amanda m'a réussi à bouger alors
rouvrez le jeu mais ils arrivent à peine à
s'en sortir ou à prendre du retard sur notre opportunité politique d'
accord pas les Canadiens qui
Schmidt était dans un accord un budget de
25 pour cent à Washtenaw notre changement pour l'
instant je prédis que nous ne les déterrerons pas le matin
dans un billet de ménage  pourrais-je amener mon
bus ici, ils veulent réduire les impôts pour chaque
Canadien, nous avons une plate-forme avec seulement
deux taux d'imposition qui serait juste pour
tout le monde un oignon avec un diplôme pas étonnant que
nous ne gagnions pas sur mon connu c'est le
moteur Waterberg ca  r frappez vous savez
que nous ne sommes pas des magasins que j'ai dit la
mère de la mère le Bobby Scott vous
non plus ce que nous faisons encore manaus maintenant
est-ce que vous savez quelque chose à propos de monsieur partager
avec tout le respect que je vous dois, vous ne serez pas
Premier ministre la question va
être sur un siège notre Université mr.  Joe Zasa
voter pour les députés verts est votre meilleure
garantie au Canada que vous n'obtenez certainement pas que le
gouvernement veuille juste que monsieur
puisse répondre à cela et nous allons
conclure longuement maintenant m.  Shue vient de regarder
les paris d'octobre en ce moment mr.  Bernier a dit
quelque chose qui est complètement faux
sous Justin Trudeau, nous verrons des déficits sans fin
signifiant plus et en travaillant, elle
tourne la vadrouille avec Trudeau étant bon
whoops faites savoir au Wiener que
cela ne fera plus un cramoisi mais vous
connaissez Kondos Hakim et avec avec avec  les
bobbies commentent sachant qu'une
famille canadienne paie plus de quatre cents
dollars par an pour cela et vous êtes
un vrai conservateur non je pense garnir
ici
conservateur négatif Maggie non libéral
le dogmatique je ne sais pas de quel Maxime
Bernie je débat  dire était-ce la
Maxine Bernie des années 1990 qui était
séparatiste était que le vaccin Bernie a
qui est ministre responsable de la distribution du
bien-être des entreprises
était-ce le massacre Maxine Bernie qui a
défendu la Suisse sur ne pas Ahmad
non russe sur moi honte sectaire en  un
méga tendu il y a un contraste clair dans
cette élection les déficits sans fin de Justin Trudeau
et les hausses d'impôts à payer pour moi mais
le jeu Abba me bon venir avec
Trudeau
aweso  moi un gagnant niggas automatique Nina
Nina qui sent drôle L entrez Domino
elle passe un autre méga sur le jeu kiddo oh
mec d'accord je veux me faire prendre Sonya était
méga brillante déchirée par les Canadiens
merci beaucoup je suis la Maxine Bernie
qui est là pour  Les Canadiens et je suis le
Maxim Burn nommé coup de soleil et OH, puis-je
faire un geste sur les questions réservées aux Canadiens
qui sont importantes pour ce que
Kannagi, qui puis-je m'inquiéter de
venir dire à nouveau, faites ce que les
Canadiens simples qu'ils font parmi
vous ne font pas  veux couper brumeux ce qu'ils
viennent une infirmière pittoresque quand tu
luttes ici la fatigue vois à quel point l'
un de nous vertical a formé un budget catégoriel de
25% pour payer les réductions d'impôts qui affaiblissent
25% va à la propriété d'Aniyah aux
Dakotas vous lui je  était ici
et nous avons vu avec mr.  diamant et John
pour commencer à marcher avec un pas arrêter
maintenant les sociétés de sensibilisation qu'il garde avec
le monde ne devraient pas s'y
opposer, même oh non des toxines ou des
chaussettes ouais il a vu avec du toner je veux obtenir
vos propres objets comment ça n'est pas moche
se moquer quand Monsieur Condon Abbas me vérifie
veut que dans un agnostique, ils vont
regarder pour s'éteindre avec la porte Nanak
choix très différent et Stephen Harper a
fait un choix très différent dans Andrew
part propose kini von Sydow Naniwa
nouveaux Canadiens gay ne me donne pas un toke
espoir Quinn Mongo tueur Canadiens d'
accord chronique nous allons trier du vinaigre
collant ou Smith oups les hommes sont homosexuels qui sont
le mod parle de T même le GABA
ne fera pas parmi les documents plus longs d'accord les
femmes doutent que nous fassions
mengwei ne  Pour aider l'économie, vous avez la
plus grande opportunité économique mondiale de
l'histoire de l'humanité en éliminant les
combustibles fossiles le plus rapidement possible.
manomètre psychotique Chaka
psychotique était avec la maternité de substitution Norma
faisait était de faire au mois de Bush
quoi faire ouais nous ne sommes pas des clés qui ne
convergent pas car je veux me battre pour les
Québécois et les Québécois seulement si nous sommes
d'accord avec le gouvernement canadien alors laissez-le
être terminer un check-out avec la pensée
signifie que nous aurons une constante québécoise à
Chicago une conversation avec moi s'est bien passé femme d'
accord d'accord
Yellin au moment où le fait est
sous justin trudeau la vie continuera
à devenir plus chère vous dépensez plus
trahi ou  donnez ma parole que le méga
gagnant de Kanagawa a engendré une connerie de manière méga équitable
, ne le gagnez pas, vous savez que la foule en
aura plus avec c'est tout
merci, cela nous amène à la fin de
ce segment et à la fin de ce
débat, nous voulons vous remercier tous
bien sûr pour avoir pris le temps pour moi
qu'il était également il avait un contact de montage
nam khan une cible de tête de canard tu viens
sur le canard
nous ne sommes pas tu es venu roi pour moi que
pouvons-nous avoir un coup pour moi bonne façon nous
avons Robinson  ré  oes pour faire Jimmy regarder
[Musique]
vous
[  Musique]
[Musique]
[Musique  ]
[  Musique]
[Musique]
vous
[  Musique]
[Musique]
vous
[  Musique]
[Musique]
[Musique  ]
[  Musique]
[Musique]